hi brian is Felix after Germany and
ametek pioneer and I wanted to answer
your question what I found most
interesting here to form the ultimate
industry an idea and that was yesterday
the speech by President Sarkozy for two
days ago and yesterday by a mr. Clinton
who both back to European Union in the
year or so president Sarkozy made a very
strong statement about that which I
liked of course that acute pain which
was that there's a lot of talk going on
about euro not being strong currency or
maybe you know things going on so I
think it was very good that President
circusy make a strong statement and also
help and Clinton asked for more action
just then time to hire so it was very
impressive to see those two presidents
making that strong statement here to all
the people in the host which is really
incredible incredible so that that was
was a that impressed me the most so
thank you and have a nice day